こちらでは救いを求めているわけじゃなくて
自分の辛苦な行動をコントロールするために見張り役を頼んでいるだけ
えーと 次の瞑想はウパサマナ・サティという瞑想で
なんですか ジャクシ・ズウィネン
ジャクシ・ズウィネンという
これすごい 難しい瞑想ですけどもね
だから一般的に理解できるところだけ言います
あの専門的にはもうちょっと瞑想は違いますけどね
専門的に言うとジャクシ・ズウィネンというのは
この涅槃をサマーディ瞑想にすることなんです
解脱 まだ解脱してるわけじゃないんです
涅槃体験してるわけじゃないんです
でも仏教を勉強すると
解脱という概念があるんでしょうね
最高な境地は解脱ですよと
最高の幸福は涅槃ですよと
涅槃より優れている幸福がないんだとも言ってるんですね
その概念を念じたり考えたりしてサマーディ瞑想をするんです
そこはまあ専門的なジャクシ・ズウィネンです
ですから そこはどうしても仏教の人はやらなくちゃいけないんですね
なぜならば あの解脱について考えて瞑想してないと
この解脱は得られたいという気持ちが出てこないんです
解脱を得たくはならなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 悟りたい悟りたいと頑張る前に
悟りということは お釈迦様の経典から何とか何とか理解しようとして
まあそれについて随念したりして
サマーディ瞑想を少しやった方がいいということなんです
そこで一般的にはどのようにジャクシ・ズウィネンしますかというと
この心を落ち着いた状態
混乱していない状態 いかに楽しいかと
そこを感じることを観察することなんです
例えば ものすごいうるさいところに行ったと
みんなキャーキャーキャーキャーとうるさくて
もう苛立ちが出てくるところにいるんだと
そこでやっぱりこれこのようにあると
あらゆる音が耳に入るんだけど
心が落ち着いて波が立たないようにいられるんだったら
いかにかっこいいかと
いかにいいかと 素晴らしいかと
そこをやってみるんです
美味しいご飯食べるところ
みんなよだれたらしながら
すごいものすごい これはああだこと
これはこうだこと あれはもうしゃべるはしゃべる
うるさいわ で 何のことなく落ち着いて
心に感動は全くしないで
やってみると いわゆる心の中で
このいわゆる悟ったわけじゃないんです
悟った人の真似をやってみるんです
そこはジャクシ瞑想なんです
みんな口と口先だけでやっても
あれはもう邪教 邪教というか
あれは地獄に落ちます
口でやるんじゃなくて
心でやるもんなんです
口でやってみんなにああだこうだ言っちゃうと
まあそれは悪行 悪行で
もう邪見でまあ決まっちゃいますけどね
それではなくて 例えば
まあ自分にとっては大変大変美味しい食べ物を食べると
やっぱりそこで食べたいと
やっぱりそれは欲であって
まあ美味しいものあるんだけど
自分が食べたい食べたくないというどっちでもなく落ち着いている気持ちをやってみる
例えばすごい自分にもう気に入ってる若い人々とか出てきて
いろいろ話したり もういろいろやっていると
でも自分が落ち着いている心でいるんだ
まあそういう風にこのいろんな環境の中で
自分の心を波立てないようにと
感情は生まれないように
落ち着いているように
あるように訓練することの瞑想なんで
それもサマーディ瞑想なんです
悟ったわけじゃないん
その前にこの面白さ その素晴らしさ
落ち着いていることのこの偉大さを味わっています
それはサマーディ瞑想
ウパサマーナ安息定です
これすごくいい瞑想なんです
これはもう誰でもやった方がいいんです
いろいろ道具作ったりするのは七面倒くさくてね
で そこでいっぱいあっちこっちは捨ててはありますけど
まあこれテレビでニュース聞くと
もうとっくにそちらに入らないんだから
もうとっくにそこはもうそこから運んでいるんだからね
まあしょうがないし だからこの瞑想っていうのは皆様やった方がいいんです
いろいろ問題は解決するだろうと
お互いに嫉妬あったり
見栄張ったり 威張ったりとかね
瞑想競争したりとかね
まあ醜い 汚いというのはもう挙げられるほどありますけど
やっぱりそこはしょうがないし
やっぱりそうやって心の落ちついてる状態
あの人よく瞑想してるんだって自分の心が落ち着いてないんです
あの人はなんだと思っちゃうと
すごい差別感でしょう
そうやって自分の周りの人々はもううるさくたっても
瞑想ろくにしなくたっても
寝込んじゃっても もうどっちでもいろいろでしょうね
人々っていうのは また来て
ご教話あまり聞いてもないのに
また文句ばっかしとかね
批判ばっかしとか 正解もしていないのに
で 一回二回の鍛え方でも
もうあなた方はこうしなさい
ああしなさいと私に言われたことがありますけどね
私の心であなたは世界一バカやと叫ぶなくたって知ってるんだって気持ちで聞いてるんだけどね
わかりましたと 落ち着いては聞いてます
であまりにも激しく言っても
あなたがどう思いますかと言ったら
いえ あなたはバカだと叫ばなくたってわかってますよと
と言いたいんですけど
まあそういう私が落ち着いてないんだから言わないのです
だからこの一応訓練として
この指導を通して 時々きついなことを言いますけど
言わないと思ったらもうもう年に一人だと言わないことは言わないんです
だからあまりにもこの成長しなくて
もうどうしようもない場合は
もう一つ殴ってやらないと
ですから 皆様方ご自分でウパサマー瞑想
ウパサマーナ瞑想なさるんだったら
本当にすごい素晴らしい人間にはなるんです
ものすごい気持ちの良い人間になっちゃう
だから名前は言いますけど
教会のこの手に負えたところはなんて言いますか
森田さん 私はいつでもいじめてるんですね
これ試してるんですね
でもすごいここ落ち着いていて
人が何言ってもそれはもう笑ってそれにものすごい優しく応えて
だからって本人がそんなことやってるっていう気持ちもなくて
だからもう全然誰ともトラブルを起こさない
だからそういうことっていうのは
いとも簡単にそんな性格って誰にでも作られます
だからもう楽しいんです
喋るとからかったり いろいろことやったりして
で この間誰かより来てや
なんかの家具でなんとかそれ組み立てを
私は出かけをしていたんです
そしたらこれから工事始まります
私は終わるまで待っていたんです
遅くなったんだけど なぜ待っていたかというと
このその人と一緒にいること
なんか楽しくて だからもうずっと私がいると邪魔なんですけど
ああだこうだなんか言いっぱなしで
それでもまあ最後はやっぱりこれプロの意見ないとうまくいかないよと言いながら
もう彼はやっぱりプロの意見聞かなきゃダメだと言いながら
それでいろいろ組み立てましたけど
やっぱり私はもう出かけようと思って
もう玄関にいたんです
それで彼が入ったんですね
それで何のことなく戻ったんだから
やっぱり人の心落ち着いているということは
いかに他人まで引くかということでしょうね
だから引かれてしまっちゃうんです
だからそこは解脱するまでまでなくても
真似すればいいんです
その口で真似するんじゃなくて
体で真似するんじゃなくて
なんか悟ったふりをしてやるとかね
心に感情の波が生まれないようにする
外へ出たら寒くていやだってことではなく
寒い まあ別にどうったことはないと
落ち着いていると 電車には満員でも乗れないぐらいだと
もうやっと乗れたところで
もう片足で立っても潰れると
そこでああだこうだと感情を作るんじゃなくて
もう落ち着いていると
そうやっていかなる場合でも
心の欲も怒りも何にも生まれないようにいるということは
常に訓練して 訓練して
この場合は欲が生まれるんだから生まれないようにするんだと
この場合は怒りが生まれるんだから怒りが生まれないようにするんだとか
という風なサマーディ瞑想があります
そのサマーディ瞑想かけてるんだから
結構いろいろ人間関係で問題があるんです
ですからなさった方がいいと
どなたでも このウパサマーナサティという瞑想
そうするとやがてしち面倒くさくなる
このウパサマーナサティ瞑想
なぜならば 常に気をつけていないと落ち着いている心で
平安の心でいられないんですね
ちょっと弱くなってくると
ちょっと疲れてくると
もう元に戻しちゃうんですね
だから我慢にも限界ありますからね
例えばすごいうるさいところで自分が落ち着いているんだと
でもこれ延々延々ときりが終わりがなく出てくると
この我慢にも限界ありまして
もう嫌だと他のところに行きますということになる可能性あります
ですから このウパサマーナ瞑想をなさっていると
やっぱりこれ結構疲れるんだと
でもこの調子はすごくいいんだということで
本物でヴィパッサナー瞑想で悟らなきゃまあやりきれんやということが分かってくるんですね
そういうためにウパサマーナサティ瞑想があります
最後は 最後じゃない まあもう時間ないな
全部終わるまでは マラナーヌッティ
そこでよくこの今日の話は大事な話なんです
だから注意して聞いてください
僕はこの一つ一つ瞑想について説明は後で思い出してみてください
やり方が違う 目的が違う
働きが違うということ
だからやたらにこの無責任で
全くこの なんていうアンティティカル
なんて言いますか 無批判的でやるもんじゃないんです
そのその瞑想には決まってるやり方があって
目的があって達するところがある
その中でやった方がいいということを私が言うならば
それはまあかなりみんなにできる
お坊様の人とかはまあこれはやった方が仏教のためにもなります
皆様のことをみんな信頼して
ああ それぐらい正確できるんだったら
私たちも勉強してみようかということで
日本から無知が消える可能性もあります
だからなぜ私は仏教を知ってほしいかっていうと
別に仏教という宗教を広げたいということよりも
やっぱり人類からね この非合理的なこの無知が消えた方が幸福でしょうし
それは誰にしたってもね
仏教徒であろうがどうであろうが
そんなことは別に関係ないんですし
無知と非合理性とか それはもう面倒くさいでしょう
本人にも我々にも 私たちの中はみんなもう無知の塊で
非合理的な感情の塊だったら面倒くさいでしょう
だから直してほしいということで
そこは証拠がないと誰も聞いてくれないでしょうし
ですから 私たちは奥様のアヌッサティ瞑想でもちょっとなさってみると
そこまで人がおとなしくなるんだったら
そこまで落ち着いて性格いいんだったらということで
みんな信頼するし それでもう日本から無知を追い払うことはできるだろうと思います
だからこれすごく必要な瞑想なんです
他人のためではなくて
一番自分のためでもありますね
あんたそこまで仏教やってまだそんな調子やと聞かれる状態ではね
困るんです まあもう時間ですが
マラナアヌッサティやりますかね
で 次の瞑想はこのマラナアヌッサティという瞑想で
これは死随念ですね そこもやっぱりまあ選ばなくちゃ
みんないいかどうか またちょっと問題で
この不浄観の瞑想と同じく
この あの まあみんなやれということでもないんです
でも我々出家においては必ずやれという瞑想
不浄観は必ずやりなさいということじゃないんです
死随念は必ずやりなさいということがあります
ですから 一般の方々についても
自分がやるべきかないかということは
それぞれ指導者から聞いた方がよろしいです
これはもういとも簡単にあの
まあ自分が死ぬんだと
死ぬ運命だと 死について観察することなんです
そこで自分の死について観察は不可能です
それはできません なぜかっていうと
生きているものを観察するんだから
これは永久的にできません
死んでもできません 死んだ瞬間にまた生まれ変わっちゃう
だから死んだ瞬間にすぐに生まれ変わって
そこからもう続いてもう生きてるんだからね
ですから この死の瞑想っていうのは
やっぱり自分には客観的にいつでも死を見えるんですね
死ということを見えるんです
そこでまあ その生命は死にますかと
まあそこを簡単でしょうに
このスーパーとか言ったら
魚屋さんとかね 遺体だらけでしょう
だからその人は死んでるんだと
遺体だと 私もそうなるんだと
みんなそこまでですと
人生の生きることのゴールは死ぬことよ
このゴールだったら何のことないものだと
という この我々の必死になって生きていきたいという
この限りない無知的なこの努力の無意味さを実感してるんです
建物を造らなくちゃいけないとかね
5億円借金しなくちゃいけないとかね
で これ買わなくちゃいかないと
あれやらなくちゃいけないとか
会社作らなくちゃいけないとか
ものすごいもう必死になってやってるでしょうに
結局一体何ですかと 何のためか
死んじゃったらもうそれだけのことでしょう
全て終わっちゃうでしょう
あれは何一つも役に立たないんです
だから人間のこのもうあまりにも無知で
もうあまりにもこの幻覚にもうやられちゃって
生きていきたい 生きていきたいっていう
この生き方の無意味さを
非論理性を 非合理的であることを実感するために
遺体を見ながら 死ぬんだ
不浄だと思うことじゃないんで
痛みてや醜い 汚いとかね
前の瞑想と違うんです
まあただまあそれで終わりと
瞑想する ですから このあの不浄観の瞑想の場合は
不浄観っていうんですか
不浄の瞑想の場合はものすごいちょっと感じが違うんです
すごくなんかね 強烈に
この場合はもうちょっと落ち着いて
ちょっともうちょっと哲学的で
もうまあ沉静な それどんどん今日あの進んでいってほしいんですね
自分の親戚が死んじゃったと思ったら
ああ大変だとかどっか驚くんじゃなくて
あ そうですかと まあまあ
私もそんなふうになるんだから
普通に取る そこまでですと
まあこれ そろそろ花が咲くでしょうと思いますけどね
頭おかしくなってもバカみたく驚くんじゃなくて
あれは死を意味しているでしょう
桜の花っていうのは 何のことないですよね
2日  3日で散っちゃうし
それで葉っぱだらけになっちゃうしね
昨日ワンサイクル終わっちゃったんだから
そこで綺麗な花はね もうみるみるうちにゴミになるし
そうやってこのどんどんどんなものも
まあその現象がまあすぐ変わるんだという風に持っていくんです
朝起きて ああ 今日 1日元気で明るく幸福で幸せで頑張るんだと
おっとと様ありがとうございますっていうの仏教的じゃないんです
いわゆるこの瞑想とは反対なんです
じゃなくて あ  1日終わった
もういわゆる死の方向へ持っていくんですね
もうずっと死んでるんだと
そういう風に持っていくと
そこもあの まあ間違ってやっちゃうとね
あんまりいい結果にはなりません
ですから気をつけて これは智慧が発達していると
この我々の生き方について
生き方にあるこの無意味さ
発見する それほどのことじゃないんだと
みんなやってるのに で
だから欲を 欲をいくらか抑えてもらう
というふうな方向へ持っていかなくちゃいけない
で 夏になってきたらあのー
ヒッカツって何ですか？蝉とかね
まあ鳴いていると ああ夏だとそんな感じじゃなくて
鳴いて鳴いて もうそろそろ死ぬと
だから死という概念で見ると何でも死なんです
全て死なんですね すっごく頭のいい人になっちゃうんです
そこでこの あや いやらしい感情とか怒りとかね
もう出てこなくなっちゃう
で この死の瞑想っていうのは
このなんか見る見る表だけはなんかすごく暗く感じますけど
そうじゃないんです やってるとどんどんどんどん力強くなって
すっごく人間らしくなっちゃうんです
余計なことってのは全部なくなっちゃう
全て無駄が消える 無駄な時間も無駄なものの使い方ももうなくなる
何が意味があるか 何が意味がないか
ちゃんと見分けできるようになっちゃうんです
そこで生きてる瞬間だから
その瞬間で有効に頑張るんだということもできるわけですね
ですから もうすごい力強い瞑想なんです
そこではヴィパッサナー瞑想の世界でも同じ瞑想は自動的に入っちゃうんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想はここから
これから説明ありますからね
あと 一緒なのかはわかりませんだけど
で この瞑想は見ているところはステップあるんです
すべての現象が生じて滅していくことを見えてくるんです
それから滅していくんだ
消えていくことだけ見えるようになっちゃうんです
だからこの基礎訓練しておけば
その発見は早いんです
とにかく死の瞑想においては
この怒り 欲というのはもう出てこなくなっちゃうんですね
喧嘩とかね 何のために喧嘩するんですかと
そういうことで あの死の瞑想っていうのはまあ大体もうやってもいい瞑想で出家の人は誰でもやります
それの遺体は要りません
どこにでもあります えーと
そこら辺でやりましょう
もう二つは残ってますけど
どうします？だからこのチャート見ると
そのその瞑想から禅定はどこまで作られるかっていうことは分かりますね
この第二段目ですか でも
とにかくこのアナパサティ
ズリニン瞑想っていうのはもう頭をしっかりするための瞑想なんです
欲をなくすために まあそれほど禅定まで持っていくということはまあ難しいです
じゃあ中途半端でしたけど
まあしょうがないです
[終始背景の雑音]